ladies and gentlemen welcome everyone
I'm - Johanna song and I will introduce
this year's winner of the Prize in
Economic Sciences and as you all know
the price this year is awarded to
Professor Richard failure at the
University of Chicago and it's awarded
the prize for his contributions to
behavioral economics and in the
traditional model in economics is based
on free simplifying assumptions
individuals assume to be fully rational
to have unlimited self control and only
be motivated by narrow self-interest and
in behavioral economics these three
assumptions are relaxed to introduce
psychologically more realistic
assumptions about human behavior and no
sorry and the model is based on in
behavioral economics introduced bounded
rationality limited self control and
that individuals are motivated also by
social preferences such as fairness
richard failure has done early and
foundational work in all these three
major areas of behavioral economics
bounded rationality limited self control
and social preferences and on the slide
I mentioned some of his major
contributions in this areas and using
his own terminology can say that we've
been going from using econ's
in the traditional model of economics to
basing model of humans in the Mallis of
behavioral economics
and this figure shows a slide or you can
think of as the methodology or framework
to do work in behavioral economics
there's an interplay between theory and
empirical evidence from experiments both
flood experiments and field experiments
and the evidence from the experiments is
used to refine the theoretical models to
improve the predictions of the theory
but importantly policy proposals is also
based on evidence from failed
experiments that's used to see what work
and what doesn't work so this is a model
of scientific inquiry that is mode
economics towards more evidence-based
economics and this is stunning in in two
ways of this term both in terms of the
theory all the time being exposed to
rigorous testing in experiments and
continuously improved but also in the
science of policy proposals being based
from randomized fail experiments and
professor failure has made important
contributions in each of these boxes or
the model and it's been instrumental in
introducing and establishing this model
of evidence-based economics it's a
pleasure and privilege to welcome this
year's winner of the price and economic
sciences professor failure place the
stage is yours
thanks Magnus thanks to all the members
of the committee and thanks for that
great introduction
so I've I've been interested in
gravitational waves for a long tono so I
I began this inquiry really with a
series of stories stories and thought
experiments and I thought what I would
do in the lecture today is give you a
sense of the path of behavioral
economics how it started from these
stories and thought experiments and we
will end up with the Swedish social
security system which is another
experiment
so maybe my most famous story involves a
dinner party and a bowl of cashew nuts
this was back when I was in graduate
school a bunch of economists were coming
over for dinner we put out a bowl of
cashews and served drinks
and after a while about half the bowl
had been consumed we were worried about
our appetites and so I took the bowl and
hid it in the kitchen and I think came
back and first of all everybody thanked
me thank God you got rid of those nuts
and then since it was a group of
economics graduate students we began to
analyze it which shows you the danger of
going to a dinner party with a group of
economists and so the the analysis was a
that we were happy and B that we were
not allowed to be happy because
it's a basic axiom of economics that
more choices are always preferred to
fewer and before we had the choice to
eat the nuts or not and now we didn't so
what were we doing being happy so how is
it that having a choice removed can make
us better off this led to a series of
papers with my friend here sheffrin
self-control my second story involves
the then chairman of the economics
department at the University of
Rochester where I was studying who I
followed in his footsteps in becoming a
wine lover and so when I met him he had
been collecting and drinking wine for a
long time and had made some wise
purchases early on possibly including
even this bottle but for this story
we're gonna say he bought a bottle for
$4.95 and later was able to sell it for
$100 and he had a rule that he wasn't
willing to pay more than $30 for a
bottle of wine but he sometimes would
drink one of his old bottles well that's
a puzzle if you're an economist he won't
buy he won't sell but he will drink so
that's kind of the economists reaction
to this and that story eventually led to
another research stream on what we'll
call the endowment effect loss aversion
status quo bias and so forth here's a
third story these are all from the same
vintage kind of when I was in grad
school
a friend and I were given tickets to a
basketball game in Buffalo we were
living in Rochester there was a big
snowstorm and we wisely decided not to
go to the game but my friend said had we
bought those tickets we would have been
we would go to that game
now of course economists call this the
sunk cost fallacy and the the question
is why would anybody think going to the
game helps so yes in that hypothetical
where we had paid a lot of money for
these tickets there would be that wasted
money but going to the game wasn't gonna
get that money back so why is it that
there was this temptation to feel like
we should go to the game if we had paid
for the tickets and this and many other
stories led to a research program on
mental accounting so I then met these
two guys these two young handsome guys
here Amos Tversky and Daniel Kahneman
and I got an idea from them the kind of
that made my research possible they were
busy studying how people make judgments
this is before they wrote their famous
paper on prospect theory and the idea
related to earlier work by herb Simon it
says okay people are boundedly rational
and so they use simple rules of thumb to
help them make decisions and then here
was the aha moment I got from reading
their research which is that the use of
these heuristics not only leads to
errors economists would have no problem
with that
we know how to add an error term
the idea was that they would lead to
systematic bias so an example is you can
ask people what do they think is the
ratio of gun deaths by homicide to gun
deaths by suicide in the United States
people think homicides are much more
frequent cause of death in fact suicides
are about twice as often that's an
example of what they call the
availability bias and it's just you can
you can win bar bets based on their
research so one lesson from these
stories is that there's a bunch of
things that economic theory tells us we
can leave out and in fact makes the
strong prediction that they simply will
not matter I call these supposedly
irrelevant factors and really my
research can be summarized as there are
a lot of these supposedly irrelevant
factors that are not irrelevant they
matter so I call these ifs supposedly
irrelevant factors so my three little
stories illustrate them if you push the
cashews just even to the other side of
the table as we've all done on occasion
you know maybe with the prior of the
delicious bread they insist on giving
you in Swedish restaurants we pushing
you to the other side of the table can
help why in the world should that help
you can reach over there and get it the
location of the bread is as if the fact
that professor rosette owned that bottle
of wine is as if his willingness to
drink it should not depend on whether he
owns it assuming he can buy and sell at
the same price and the sunk cost is
another sip
how much we paid for the tickets
shouldn't affect our decision
go to the game so once we realize that
there's this long list of sifts we can
expand the predictive power of economic
theory because a lot more stuff matters
so how do we get from stories to science
I'm gonna illustrate that with one
experiment that I did with my friends
Daniel Kahneman and Jack connect and
you'll see the the mug here is place a
crucial role in this my last remaining
mug is now in the Nobel Museum so I
stole these Legos from my grandchildren
and you'll see they're gonna play a
crucial role in in this little
illustration so here's how the
experiment works we start using a
technique that was invented by Vernon
Smith who shared the Nobel Prize with
Danny Kahneman 15 years ago and in using
vernon smith's technique we assign
values to people so we do that by saying
if you end up with one of these tokens
at the end of the experiment you can
redeem it
for the value indicated here then we
assign tokens at random which we've done
here and incidentally my friend linea
who produced all these beautiful slides
has assigned these at random in the way
that condiment and Tversky would say is
the most random looking way of us
randomly
assigning nicely done Linea so we've
assigned these at random and now we
conduct a market in which we allow
people to trade so people who don't have
tokens can buy them people who have
tokens can sell them and then we see
what happens and this is what happens
yeah which is exactly what is supposed
to happen and this is an example of
what's called the coast theorem named
after Ronald Coase 1991 Nobel laureate
his basic idea is that in a market where
transaction costs are low as they are in
this experiment then the initial
assignment of property rights which in
this case was done at random will not
effect the eventual allocation of
resources and we see that's true here
the people the guys the Legos on the top
row who really love tokens end up with
all the tokens okay now we have the
Legos back and here the values we've now
arranged the Legos in the order in which
they like a Cornell coffee mug so that
guy in the left really wants one of
those mugs it's worth $20 to M whereas
whoever that guy is
in the bottom right Wood has no interest
in a Cornell mug maybe it doesn't like
Cornell or it doesn't love coffee or
what-have-you
so now we're gonna do the same random
assignment coincidentally just the same
way in the very random looking
assignment and now we're gonna do a
another market just the way we did with
tokens
if the Coase theorem worked again the
people who love the mugs most would end
up with all the mugs what actually
happened well we got about a third as
much trading as we should have and the
reason for that was that the people who
had mugs didn't want to give them up but
the people who didn't have mugs were not
that interested in buying one so what
did we learn from this two things one is
we can't learn much about human behavior
by running experiments in which we
assign values to people because that's
not the way life works when we go into
the market there's nobody telling us
what we should pay for that loaf of
bread or that bundle of Swedish
meatballs and when we deal with the real
world then we observe two little trading
why well it's kind of over determined
part of it is loss aversion the idea
that it hurts more to give something up
than to acquire it and there's also
something called status quo bias which
we will see again later where people
tend to stick with whatever they have
and there are other factors that are
reinforcing these we know what we have
and we kind of like it and something
else we're not sure what what we would
get and then there's just our basic
laziness that the sort of thing that
when we're watching television we can
find ourselves watching the show that
comes on on the same station we've been
watching even though the
cost of switching is exactly one thumb
click so as Magnus mentioned one of the
questions we asked in behavioral
economics is what happens if we relaxed
assumptions of unlimited rationality and
unlimited willpower so we deal with
humans and suppose that these humans are
not all as smart as Einstein and don't
have perfect self-control they're more
like Homer Simpson then what well let's
take another Nobel prize-winning theory
this one from Franco Modigliani that's
called the life cycle hypothesis this is
the standard economic model of saving
for retirement so let me just illustrate
how that's supposed to work it's
basically two steps first figure out how
much you expect to make over your
lifetime how long you're gonna live then
decide how you'd like to smooth
consumption over that lifetime and then
do it so here's an illustration here's a
very simple case suppose your income is
going to steadily increase until you
reach 65 at which point you retire and
stop earning money and suppose you
wanted to have a perfectly flat
consumption profile then you would
borrow early in your life you would save
later in your life and then you would
just save and you would when you were 20
you would formulate that plan and then
you would do it now of course life is
more complicated than that
for example income might have
unexpected changes so oops you get laid
off and you go to Silicon Valley and
make a bundle of my UPS there's a the
startup doesn't do so well but then you
write them then you write a book so you
know that that's those are income
surprises we can have consumption
surprises that sports car was
irresistible kids move back in kids
don't even think about it maybe the
grandchildren they're cute but then you
know you get old and all kinds of stuff
happens that you don't anticipate so you
can see this is hard and so people might
need some help
and the econ's in economic theory don't
need any help they can just figure all
this out they can figure out what they
need to do and they don't have any
self-control problems so they just do it
now this is a new problem that humans
face we've been around for millions of
years they tell us and for most of our
time on earth saving for retirement was
not something anyone needed to worry
about the reason is you would die first
so those that did manage to live long
enough to be able to stop working
the solution was move in with their kids
who conveniently were living next door
and still were willing to have their
parents move in and then in the 20th
century these norms started to break
down the kids moved away parents started
living longer and so we had to solve
this problem
and some of the solutions the early
solutions were things like social
security systems and companies
sponsoring defined benefit pension plans
and those are the old plans where what
you you got an annuity based on how long
you worked and what you made and these
plans were very easy for us humans
because there were no choices
you just you got taxed on your income
and then you got your Social Security
payments the same with your job you
worked there were you there were this
the retirement with all in the
background and then when you retired you
got this annuity and life was easy
well firms and countries discovered that
especially pay-as-you-go pension plans
can lead to problems and so they created
new strategies called defined
contribution plans and in these are much
harder for humans humans have to decide
whether to join the plan and then if
they join how much to save and then if
they yeah and then how to invest that
money and some people don't bother to
join those who join may not save enough
or may not invest particularly wisely
and notice that the traditional model is
of no help whatsoever in solving this
problem because it assumes people have
solved it and if they're not saving
enough well that's because they don't
expect to live very long or are happy
not having very much when they retire so
if they're just saving the right amount
you have no advice to give them
and there's no reason to offer them help
so how can behavioral economics help
well one way is using what Cass Sunstein
and I refer to as choice architecture so
choice architecture is the environment
in which we make decisions so one
example is a menu if you go to a
restaurant the chef has decided what he
or she wants to cook but there's
somebody at the restaurant whose job is
to write that down into a menu and it
could be a simple menu you can have a
four-course or a six-course dinner and
you have no choices or it could be you
know one of these menus at a Chinese
restaurant that seems to be endless and
so one lesson from a virile economics is
that what you order will depend on the
structure of the menu and in an Italian
restaurant if the pasta courses are in a
separate category people will order
differently then if they are mixed in
with the other appetizers or entrees
store layouts again if you assume people
just go to the store and buy the optimal
bundle then the way the store is
arranged won't matter it'll be another
sip
but stores have learned that's not right
and they spend a lot of money figuring
out how they want you to walk through a
supermarket and make sure you pass by
the things that are most profitable and
they stick things like milk in the back
of the store because that's the thing
you buy most often and your be sure to
walk by a lot of tempting other things
when you go by places like Amazon of
course
I've spent billions thinking about
choice architecture so one of the
lessons of choice architecture and the
title of the book Cass and I wrote is
that the choice architecture can
influence what we pick because it will
include what we call nudges so what our
nudges dodges are features of the
environment that influence the behavior
of humans but would not influence the
behavior of econ so we're an item is on
the menu doesn't affect Homo economicus
but it does affect us so the feature of
nudges that we stress in our book is
that nudges are a way to influence
choices without forcing anyone to do
anything and we called the philosophy we
espoused libertarian paternalism many
people did think this phrase was an
oxymoron
we wrote a paper called libertarian
paternalism is not an oxymoron
a law professor wrote in another paper
saying libertarian paternalism is an
oxymoron I was lobbying with gas that we
should write a rejoinder that says no
it's not Reason prevailed so what are
some nudges maybe the most powerful
nudge we have in our arsenal is simply
to change the default so what what is
the default the default is simply what
happens if you do nothing now we're
really good at doing nothing passivity
is one of humans greatest skills
so an application of this idea in the
domain of pension plans is what's come
to be known as automatic enrollment so
in the old system when you were first
eligible for the pension plan you there
were a bunch of forms you had to fill
out and you'd have to decide how much to
save and then how to invest there could
be a big long pile of these forms some
people like my friend castes are very
norm averse forum averse and if casts us
to fill out a form
he's almost certain not to do it so what
does automatic enrollment do it says you
get the same pile of forms but on the
top page it says if you don't fill these
forms out we will enroll you in the
pension plan have this saving rate and
in this fund and you don't have to do
anything so that's a sip right the
default is this if it takes a minute or
two to fill out these forms so it
shouldn't matter does it matter yes big
time so this is some data from Vanguard
that administers thousands of these
plans the purple lines are the
percentage of people that are enrolled
for plants that use automatic enrollment
the gray lines are for those that don't
and you can see for any income group
about 90% of the people join if we use
automatic enrollment much less for other
groups particularly for lower income
groups so this this is this is a nudge
that's particularly effective at helping
lower-income people save for retirement
well there's a problem with automatic
enrollment and that is
particularly in the United States the
firms that employ this strategy almost
universally enroll people at too low of
a level often 3% of income that is not
enough to save for retirement so how can
we solve this problem my former students
loma been artsy and i took this on and
what we decided to do is think about
this starting with the psychology and
and ask well what is it that's
preventing people from saving enough
well one is self-control problems we can
go out for a fancy dinner tonight
that's tempting we're saving for
retirement that's some time off in the
future and we know people have more
self-control for the future then for now
many of us are planning diets not this
week
certainly maybe after the new year
the second is loss aversion that I've
previously mentioned people don't like
to see their income go down so we wanted
to take that into consideration and then
inertia people are good at doing nothing
so our idea was we know these things are
preventing people from saving let's flip
the problem around and use those to
create a plan that will take those
weaknesses if you want to call it that
and use them to help so the plan we
created we called save more tomorrow and
the basic idea was to invite people now
to save more later because
self-control is easier for later it's
like the our diet plan that will start
in January and particularly to invite
them to save more when they get their
next raise so they won't see their
income go down that will eliminate the
loss aversion and then we're gonna keep
that up until they hit some goal so
we'll get inertia working for us so we
spent years trying to get any company to
try this and we finally found one in
Chicago and in this particular
implementation the company was a small
company they hired a financial advisor
and offered his services to any employee
it was about 300 employees and for most
of them he the advisor said we think you
should save at least five percentage
points more and most of the employees
said that you're nuts I can't afford
that so then and only then were they
offered the same or tomorrow plan and it
was a quite an aggressive one they're
saving was increased by three percentage
points every time they got a raise so
notice this is all a SIF right with life
cycle savers a they would have no
interest in joining save more tomorrow
because they're already saving the right
amount and if it was put in they would
undo it because they are already saving
the right amount so so it shouldn't work
a no one should join and be their
behavior won't change well let's see
what happened the first line of this
chart are the people who said they
didn't want to talk to this financial
advisor and you can see
the inertia in this system these numbers
fluctuate a little it's not that anyone
is doing anything it's in there's
attrition so we some people leave the
company then here is the group that took
the advice to go up by five percentage
points you can see they did that and
then stopped then here are our guys and
you can see we almost quadrupled saving
rates using supposedly irrelevant
factors now a question we asked and and
we were asked at hundreds of workshops
yes but maybe you get them to save more
over here but then they're undoing it
somewhere else that you can't see and
for thirty years or so I was trying to
figure out how to test and possibly
reject this alternative hypothesis I
never could find the data that would
allow me to do that
fortunately in Scandinavia there are no
secrets
and so the great young economist
rush Shetty and some colleagues were
able to test this hypothesis in nearby
Denmark and here's essentially what they
did they looked at people who switched
jobs where their pension contributions
went up by at least three percentage
points and you can see what happens to
their pension saving it goes up and they
write so this is people being passive
the way we've seen in the other things
I've shown you so far but what are they
doing in their other behavior
here's their company pensions nothing
here's their other saving nothing so no
we're not stealing from some other pot
it's all net saving okay let me end with
some new research I've been doing with
two of my former students Henrik
cronquist who's Swedish and Frank you
who's not this is a multinational team
and it involves as the locals may know
in 2000 Whedon introduced something they
called the premium pension system and it
has the following key features there's a
16% payroll tax that goes to fund Social
Security 2.5 percent is directed toward
this new premium pension system there
were four hundred and fifty options in
this plan essentially any mutual fund
approved by the EU that wanted to get in
was allowed in now when it was launched
the system had two nudges now they
weren't called nudges because we hadn't
coined that term yet but they were not
just nonetheless so nudge number one was
there was a default if you didn't fill
out a form then you would be given this
default fund with the spiffy title a p7
and so anybody who didn't want to make a
choice was in that fund and then some
people who
attractive and was actually a pretty
well-designed fun with low fees they
would also get that that choice that
fund has done pretty well so all the
economists I know here claim they
actively picked it I want to tell those
people we now have your data so we're
gonna be checking so we're gonna call
these delegate errs they delegate their
investment decisions to the people at a
p7 nudge number two and this one is a
bit curious the government decided that
in spite of creating this thirteen basis
point globally diversified fund really
people should choose their own
portfolios from this array of 450 funds
and they launched a big advertising
campaign saying choose for yourself it's
your duty as a Swedish citizen to create
the best possible portfolio so the
government advertised that was the
largest advertising campaign in Swedish
history it was supplemented by funds
advertising as well saying yes juice for
yourself and in particular choose our
fund these ads were not particularly
informative here's here's one
so Indiana Jones thinks you should
invest in whatever this fund is it's
kind of a scary picture I'm not my wife
used to teach advertising I don't know
whether she would approve of this ad but
anyway there were those ads and so what
happened we have a battle of the nudges
the default versus the urging which one
our Theory doesn't tell us anything
about that but the the ad campaign won
so 2/3 of Swedish citizens decided to
form their own portfolios the rest took
the default now since then new people
entered the system mostly young people
entering the workforce for the volta
first time or immigrants the advertising
campaigns stopped both the government
and the funds stopped advertising and
there were some lingering effects of
those some people are joining just a
month after the campaign ended but then
it wore out and here's what happened so
you can see this is year one when two
thirds of the people chose their own
portfolios that tapered off and in
recent years almost no one is choosing
their own portfolio those numbers on the
right are about half a percent so that's
kind of interesting right so
but one of the questions we're
interested in is well how long do not
just last right so those guys on the
left were well actually until 2008 they
were locked in there was an obscure rule
the justification of which no one has
been able to explain to me but if you
maybe somebody here knows but if you
turn down the default fund you weren't
allowed to take it later until 2008 then
they changed that rule but so one of the
question is those guys who were nudged
to be individualistic did they stay that
way and if so that would be interesting
because almost no one has chosen to do
that since so 27 percent of the people
in the default fund have left and
decided to become do-it-yourselfers but
essentially no one that started as into
it yourselfer has switched their so this
nudge has lasted more or less forever
and that's in spite of the fact that the
default fund has had drastic changes so
in 2010 the managers of the fund decided
they wanted to juice the returns well
hopefully so they decided to add
leverage you know what does that mean
technically they were borrowing and
buying options but the details of that
are not important you they initially had
a hundred and twenty five percent
leverage meaning
that if the market went up 10% the fund
would go up 12 then they switched a 50%
leverage so 50% leveraged means that if
the market goes up 10% you go up 15% but
if the market Falls 10% of the fund
Falls 15% now in hindsight these guys
look like geniuses since the market has
pretty much steadily gone up since they
took these but we can ask what would
happen if we had another financial
crisis so what would this fund have done
in the period 2006 to 2008 the answer is
down 82% so you know this is a pretty
big change and so a question that Frank
and Henrik and I have been exploring is
did anybody notice this so by the way
there are now 900 funds because 450
really wouldn't do so and one of those
900 funds is identical to the default
fund but has no leverage so it was
possible if you liked the thing you were
in and these guys in the room and I know
who you are who claim they picked the
default fund by choice in their wisdom
I'm looking at you pear presumably they
were picking an unlevered fund and you
know might have noticed that Jesus thing
has gotten a lot of risk maybe I should
switch into this other fund that's just
like the one I
allegedly actively picked so did anyone
notice so here's a plot of the leverage
over time this is the number of people
that were leaving the default fund I
don't know whether you can read those
numbers the the scale goes from 0 to 400
maybe up to 600 there are 3 million
investors in this fund so our conclusion
is we cannot reject the hypothesis that
3 million Swedish investors are asleep
they may be asleep we cannot rule that
out they certainly are not deserting the
fund in droves so what can we conclude
from this
the first is nudges can be quite
powerful
both the nudge of creating a default
which has recently been all powerful and
the earlier nudge saying please don't
take the default that was also very
powerful second and this we've never
been able to test before Thank You
Sweden for giving us this opportunity we
now know nudges can last at least 17
years possibly longer and it's
suggesting a new marketing campaign for
our nudging efforts
so let me conclude it is possible many
people told me early on it's just not
possible to do economics any other way
it wouldn't be economics so that's not
true it's possible to do economics
without homo economics sorry second if
we learn from other social scientists we
can improve economics we can increase
its explanatory power and it can give us
all kinds of new tools that we can use
to improve people's outcomes so in short
we can nudge for good
thank you
you